vous êtes face à un homme mûr
physiquement encore au point et qui
enseignent l'art d'écrire des jeune
femme très attirante
parfois il ramènerait chez lui l'une
d'entre elles afin de lui enseigner
l'art d'aimer maintien lydia emma c'est
quelque chose vous revenez au sujet de
cette barbara elle s'appelle barbara oui
tu courais après cette étudiante
la mère de barbara jetterait vous parlez
au chaud paix qu'est ce qu'elle veut
ils ont peut-être trouvé le corps de la
gamine vous lisez trop de polars mais je
suis sûr c'est ici sur le campus que
tout s'est joué
qu'est ce qui se passe mal rien vous
êtes un charmeur marque un dangereux
c'est tiré comme des mouches pas vrai
arrêtez anna annie tu t'éloignes de moi
je sens comme un courant électrique
lorsque vous ne touchez plus en bas âge
je n'ai aucune inquiétude à avoir de mon
côté tu es ma soeur je t'aime points
je suis
et nous
comment apprendre ces jeunes créatures
le choix de l'amour l'invention d'une
phrase la création d'un rythme pour
traduire cette sensation le renouveau
c'est quoi votre problème
je ne suis pour rien dans cette sphère